it's a feeling it's like love love
you don't ask yourself what is love
should i do this
no if you are struck you're struck i was
struck
by psychic power within and it made me
go
every day loyal to the cold water
in freezing water for 25 years
every winter and that made me able to
connect and change my neurology
and then at a certain moment by the
newspaper
they came to know that there was a guy
going into freezing water under the ice
and disappear and that was
not possible yoga was something unheard
of
and going into cold water you are crazy
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is the iceman
wim hof he has more than two dozen
guinness world records
he's run a half marathon above the
arctic circle
while barefoot wearing only shorts
he's run a full marathon through
africa's namib desert without even
drinking water
he stood and packed ice for hours at a
time
without his core body temperature
dropping and
he summited some of the world's largest
mountains dressed in only
shorts this guy is crazy he
is always pushing his body to the limit
but what
comes through so much from him in the
show
is just his passion his excitement
and he is an absolute inspiration
i love i love how many times in his book
called the wim hof method
uh activate your full human potential
but he says anything that i can do
you can do as well and i think that
that's a great message
so enjoy this episode enjoy the energy
that wim hof brings
and all that he has to teach us
you hear me good yeah oh my gosh thank
you for doing this uh right uh
where are you i'm in amsterdam
i love it there when i was a kid i lived
in england when i was racing
and um went over to amsterdam for
for a race one time and actually i've
been there a couple times
it's a very cool town how but how is it
now to be
one woman in a man's world racing
and winning of these guys how did you do
that that is pure the power of the mind
well no better person to talk to about
that
than you but yeah it is i mean you just
have to have
i think uh believing like to really
believe something which includes i feel
like a lot of the things that you do
visualizing like you have to be able to
see it right yes
yes yes exactly
what i can say about that directly and
and
that showed through brain scans
in the pioneering studies in psychiatry
how to uh how to change the neurological
pathways
in your own brain more than
knowing possible by humans
or ever studied now people who are
outliers like yourself being in a man's
world
is a there are protocols they act
different behave different
behave differently women women different
to a
man and then hey you can't be part of
the game but that is inventive
for men to compete with each other
that is all neurology it's all neurology
pathways
conditioning and uh to get
in there and to find a way to
beat them in their own literally game
is uh yeah it's just bloody amazing and
you know that is amazing what you did
and but it also exemplifies that women
are able to tap into
the the mindset of a man
in the air conditioning and beat them at
their game
hey that that that is marvelous that is
exemplified that women and men
are uh not only equal they uh
they they still needs to be
done a lot of work to show that
everybody is equal
because we all have a mind and that's
what i
showed within a psychiatry
sport is one thing but hey depression
how about depression depression is a
product
fruit of our thinking our conditioning
our behavior and why can we not
change it why do we need all kinds of
things from the outside
inside like antidepressants and
pills and therapies and all that
while we have a mind and we are talking
in songs about the unlimited power of
the might
and things and the love where is it man
where
is it this is what i want to show
and because people don't listen when i
say things like that
hey man he looks like a hippie must be a
hippie
don't take him serious so i showed it
through science and through uh
all kinds of challenges like yourself
you know they challenge
your body you see it you visualize you
begin to feel that you can do something
because you go
from the gut you go not
into untrotted pathways you go where
nobody has gone
before because you are in competition
you can't rely on what is being said
you got to be better so there you have
only one companion
that is your own gut feeling
and that gut feeling i learned
by going into nature uh to develop
a feeling pure feeling
pure power in my body
nothing to do with any thought or
controlling by
thought no it was simply there going
into the core order
is called what is the most
uh aggressive uh impact on the body
possible
it's freezing water you die and
yeah either a person not trained will
die in 10 minutes or
15 minutes or something and it can it
all
shuts down and fire is maybe even uh
more
you know your parish on fire in uh
in one minute or two minutes or
something
but you have you've been on the brink of
death like
your whole life i feel like in reading
your book i'm like
you like fell asleep building an igloo
when you were a kid
you got a really terrible bacterial
infection
like your birth even just how you were
born
was a crazy story yes
you know sometimes some guys just get at
all
and why they're not suddenly nobody
knows why
why why now i've got the answers
i've got the answers and the answers is
that everybody has a mission in life
and my mission had to appear
without me asking for it and
over it overcame within
my life and uh it's erased a
deep soul surge it raised a question
why and that began with that became
also the intrinsic feeling i wanna
i want answers i get this feeling i want
answers i don't know how but i will find
answers and it took me on a path and
soul search and uh when i was 12 i was
reading
into psychology hinduism and all and
when i was 17 i had to write so much
already and gone into so many
traditions religions philosophies
doctrines
practices etc then i found
cold water just suddenly
spontaneously on a winter day
uh i felt the attraction went in and
there i felt something i could not have
read or experienced any time by
books or by philosophy or by debating
you at a certain moment you are ready to
dive deep into the psych
and that at that moment at 70 years i
i went in and since then every day
every winter i went into the
cold freezing water sometimes i sat
outside the door
in shorts just to see if this was all
possible
throughout all the night in my shorts
you know what is that
that that is an absolute a tangible
great drive to do something you don't
know why you do it for
so do you think that it's that you
have been in this place where you've
nearly died many times
and life has been challenging even you
talked about being into psychology and
hedonism
buddhism all of these other religions
like you grew up
catholic your mom was super super
catholic and so
you've kind of been you've been in this
challenging position so
was cold water just meeting you where
you were and helping push you along
or do you think that going into the cold
water
was a completely different mission
based calling that you couldn't
understand but was
within you yes it absolutely met
the depth i was looking for you know
you do something you are attracted by
but you don't know the outcome
and then suddenly the outcome match
completely what i was looking for
so it says then i began to explore more
and the thing is when you go into cold
water you learn to breathe
deep what you do is
that you learn suddenly that through
breathing you are
able to change the chemistry within the
body making it
strong you are able to become strong
while being
in cold water and that may be able to
control that strength
within to uphold or withhold
these the strength of the impact of the
freezing water coming
in and changing my biochemistry inside
willfully i learned that and that made
me able at a
certain moment to stay for one hour or
two hours
in freezing water that means
something needs to oppose the impact
and that is inside and then i did that
uh many times like 20 years 25 years
on my own i just felt good
because good feeling is a good psych
you feel it it is not there in thoughts
it's a feeling it's like love love you
don't
ask yourself what is love should i do
this
no if you are struck you're struck i was
struck
by psychic power within and it made me
go
every day loyal to the cold water
in freezing water for 25 years
every winter and that made me able to
connect and change my neurology
insight and then at a certain moment
by the newspaper they came to know that
there was a guy
going into freezing water under the ice
and disappear and
that was not possible you know and those
times
and especially because my mother was
catholic the whole thing was kept with
the
the religion and the belief and the
experience and the protocols and the
behavior
so if somebody was into those straight
religions yoga was something unheard of
and going into cold water you are
crazy not all that
i tried to uh seclude myself
there from really and that made me 25
years
doing it completely on my own and then
from one day on another
somebody came to know a journalist that
i was doing that
and he made a a little article
about boom television television
so many stations for 10 days in a row
and suddenly my name began to appear
and they called me the penguin the the
ice frog and then the ice bed and the
polar bear
then the ice man like evolution do you
like him
yeah yeah man that's a batman superman
iceman of course that
that characters they the ego of course
enormously but um
the thing is i had done this uh almost
for three decades on my own
it has and had not got anything to do
with an ego
it was practice pure psych going every
day
into my water was like uh something
so familiar so uh so me
a a day is saying that i was an iceman
and i said
i tell everybody listen i'm a simple man
yet i'm changing the world and how
i will tell you and that means that if i
got that quality
you got the quality everybody has the
quality
to change the world and especially now
we got to change the world
to change the way of the way we think
can we yes you have shown that
and i have shown this in brain scans
to go into parts of the brain thought
of in science in psychiatric signs
they thought of is not possible by
humans
and i just went robustly into it
not a little bit big time and then they
say
uh suddenly say yeah we now
found the compelling evidence
of the key components of the
autonomous processes in the brain
related to mood regulation that's a long
sentence
but this is being published they saw me
going
into part of the brain they thought of
this is
not possible at will to do by a human
and then they said hey but wim hof is
he just showed it and those are the keys
to learn to regulate your mood something
the key was always lost so people had no
key to enter
into those parts of their brain to
regulate
their own mood so nobody likes to be
depressed but nobody likes to be unhappy
but we don't know how to tap in
and change it when it is bad so
now we found the keys to do so and for
that we needed people like yourself
like me showing there are there is more
than meets the eye
and there is more than the common way of
thinking
and here here it is so for that
i salute you uh uh danica
for what you have done is great and now
you are sharing this
through podcasts with uh other people
like
yourself to the world to show that we
can
learn to regulate our own mood
and with that pass it on to our children
to be happy you cannot buy it's nothing
to do with power it's power within
it's already there awakened to the
ability
the innate capacity the innate ability
to regulate your own mood
you want to be happy here it is
where did you so is it natural for you
to
was it i guess the first question was it
ever hard
was it ever hard to go in the water
every day
no uh absolutely no no
to me it was that in the beginning it
was a revelation
a psychic or revelation wow i can do
this
wow and the rush i felt afterwards
was like drugs it was like cocaine
i have taken one time cocaine my life
and and never again you know why because
the cocaine
cannot beat the feeling the ribbon
from going into cold water it's it's
what it is
cocaine is like wow hey yeah here i am
you go into the cold water and then you
really
are because you're just affecting your
brain chemistry right
so you can do it with cold water or you
can do it
synthetically or however else you want
but cold water has
you know as you list in the book and
with everything you talk about um
basically it benefits you in every
single way
so how did you i mean how did you come
up with like how were you able to stay
so dedicated where did the
dedication come from
if you feel good with something you
always go back
so if something is so strong
man i don't want to live mediocre
i want to be the joker
every day like big time
i met what is his name again
jim carrey we did the breathing and
everything he played
sort of the joker you know this uh
this film etc and you know that's
the outer ego the deeper the
your deeper being if you feel your
deeper being
then you don't want something else you
want to feel it
and and for that i go once a day
at least in wintertime outside
and have a swim have a meeting with my
deeper self
and it goes without words it's there
i think that call is a noble force it
brings
a and brings you to your kingdom
your queendom your being
just being shining being
so that that that makes that makes it
easy
to go because you don't want to feel
this
uh the normal way uh oh
nice and warm there no i want to
feel real strength and that
real strength the cold is really a a
the most direct way to make you shut up
and feel who you are and what you are
that's why i do that always
[Music]
i'm gonna confess there's a couple
things that
are really hard for me one a hundred
percent
is cold water like i absolutely
hate being cold i want you to know i've
been taking cold showers though because
you say a
cold shower a day keeps the doctor away
but i want to
go back to you talking about you know
wanting to live your best life and if
something feels good why don't you keep
doing it it makes me think about
how in life we're around
people sometimes that don't want to live
like that
that don't want to live their best life
that are negative that are
lazy um that aren't that aren't nearly
as committed and
so did being like that was it
helped by the people that you were
around or
did you have to evolve beyond sometimes
your circles because i think that
you know for people listening sometimes
they're they're stuck in this cycle with
certain people in their life and it's
really hard to
stay dedicated to something or stay
positive with the people around them so
you know what was it like for you to
reach that to
to be able to stick with it like you did
and keep on evolving and growing
did the people around you have to do the
same or did they fade away
i i lost my wife in 95
in the superstart and
she was going like psychically
downward and all psychiatry could not
help her
all the pills and injections and nothing
else
she jumped from eight stories down that
that is not only
feeling uh heart broken it's it squeezes
the
the life area the the sense of life the
purpose
and anything it's it's all gone
it's okay you are damaged at that moment
you're lying on the ground you don't
want to
uh you don't want to stand up you don't
know why
you shoot anymore because half of your
life is gone after
the separation is torn within you are
wounded a wounded animal a wounded being
inside and a society doesn't give a [ __ ]
so you need to stand up or stay there or
be brought into psychiatric asylum or
lunatic asylum or something no i had
four children
i had four children with her she was the
love of my life i was heartbroken
and had four children with her and they
were young
they needed me so they made me survive
and the sense of going into cold water
was directly there because the the mind
keeps on
running circles painfully
you know you ask yourself why why why
directly driven from a broken heart
you get that and the cold water
makes your mind go still
it was the only moment every day
i got so deep that i was not into
suffering
that i had a moment where i met myself
in the depth and hey hey
nothing there can you imagine when you
are depressed
and suddenly a moment of relief a moment
of sunshine after months
of clouds sunshine comes
and that made me go every day
into the cold water you know that the
cold of your emotional being
broken is much colder than going into
freezing water
so the freezing water made me able to
see the sun
again and that i always say that my
children make me survive
the cold healed me
[Music]
it did and you know what uh danica right
now with the psychiatrist in the world
i show in the brain scans that we can
beat
depression schizophrenia bipolar son we
are doing right now
depression in san francisco all with
this method
coming from a heartbroken man who
honestly
wants to be the father and make a nest
for
their his children uh because his love
is gone
and he is brokenhearted so he needs to
be strong
he needs to be warm he needs to have all
the energy and i got it
and still i feel the emotion right now
i'm not a cold
hearted person i'm a warm hearted person
but i'm healed
as well and still the emotion is there i
can't talk about it
it's still fresh as it is i can
i feel crying right now but
it's there and that's because you listen
also well
this is human this is beautiful this is
what makes us beautiful
and this is what i wish everybody so
if we are able to be racing and
beat everybody and or i do what i do and
i
make so many world records and and all
that
that is nice but if we can beat
depression out of this world
as schizophrenia and and bad feelings
and
hurt feelings and also disease
amen there we got a a real reward of
our focused attention concentration
training
or what we did with our mind and i am
into that and you are into that right
now
so a laureate for the work
you do laureate for the work we do
and we will pass this on and say that it
is simple
that it is here the power of the mind to
get
out of a difficult situation when you
got
into misery and you haven't got the
tools to get
out now we hand them over to the people
like the first time when somebody run
within a hundred meters
within uh 10 seconds a year and that's
in the mind
so and then a year later 10 15 people
could do it
they were there before as well
physically
but they could not do that that is the
mind
so now it shows that
uh professors tell wim half has
found when harvest dropped out from
school
yeah very bad very bad
for the system consistent this is very
bad
but the day that we show that
out there is a lot more and we are able
to
cover uh uh things
this system is not able to cover or does
not want to cover
or to uh to solve and
we just bring it and we bring it out
there so
we showed i showed now inside
a with the psychiatrist this is a
transformational technique that will
change uh mental health care that that's
what we
that that's what we need to do and
that's what we are doing we are
we are in the matrix man and we are
doing it
and we don't know what's coming but we
are ready to get into
the unknown and we got to it because we
have the power of our mind
it's amazing well you said it there's a
lot of people that
don't want these techniques
to be common because there's no money
and wellness for these
giant pharma companies you know there's
no there's no money in wellness when all
you have to do is sit by yourself and
breathe
right that's a big system to be up
against
yeah yeah it's a big monster is present
and it loves us to be
the clients and that means we need to be
sick
to make to give them the money uh
through to to be dependent so they can
control
us so it is time that we begin to wake
it
up to our internal innate capacities
to regulate our own happiness
our strength and our health and it has
all been shown
in universitarian studies that it is
there
suddenly we are able to go
after hundreds of years of scientific uh
written statements and knowledge
building up
uh literature suddenly
somebody is tapping into like the first
man running
within the ten seconds suddenly there is
a first man
showing that the uh the autonomic
nervous system can be influenced deeply
the immune system can be influenced
deeply
especially now that is a big use issue
they don't talk about it they don't talk
about the immune system they talk about
mouth caps
and uh and social distancing which
does not work it is not factual what
works is
they get you a boost your own
immune system can we do that yes in
within
a half hour we showed in a half hour or
in 10 minutes 10 minutes to activate the
adrenal axis in the body
through these breathing techniques while
lying on a bed feeling eyes
kind of and that they measured
the level of adrenaline spiking
at that moment in these breathing
exercises
more than somebody's level of adrenaline
when it goes into its first bungee jump
and i bungee jumped so i get it yeah
you see what what i mean we are the
masters
over our hormonal system and the
hormones make
up all kinds of messages and
neurotransmitters within the body
to regulate whatever is wrong to
become back into balance but we
have never schooled how to master or
known how to master or to be
with what we are born with to the
ability to be happy
strong and healthy it is all there
we have shown this and many other
studies it shows that we have these
innate capacities but this system is
which is sodimizing the planet polluting
the planet exploiting the planet
and making people insensitive to each
other and to the planet
and to the nature and the cruelty and
all that
it's like we are not connected with our
deeper
self with our heart sensitivity
with our being the purpose of life
itself no we serve a system we
they make us ready to serve a system
that is
destroying the planet and they don't
care and they keep on going
they're like murderers and i say stop
guys stop kids just be happy strong and
healthy
here it is
hmm yes i completely agree with all of
that
um man i
i was really i was really taken by
reading the story about
the vagus nerve test that you did
and the what transpired after that
yes so yes if i go back
in 2007 i was in the feinstein
institute in manhattan new york
and that was one day after i did a
documentary for 2020
on the tv medical what was it medical
mysteries or something and they wrote a
book about it i was the
human popsicle in that book
how was it possible that a guy is able
to stay for hours in direct contact with
eyes and not change his core body
temperature
and all kinds of things were written
there
but that was also a documentary with abc
news that was
and part of that documentary was to go
to
the feinstein institute it's a
biochemical institute
and it is so to the researchers on the
vegas now
so i came in into the uh
institute they put me in the chair they
got me
tubed with the blotter transfusion you
know where the way they take the blood
out of me and then the other uh
arm at the heart and uh the lung meter
and because i i just do what i do
which is the breathing exercises the
uh lung meter thought i
because i was not breathing for two
minutes uh in a consecutive
they thought the machine was defect they
did not know
they were not aware of what i was doing
so they took it out
one machine took it brought in a new
machine
and they took it out again and then with
the third machine
i i was really on and i give the best i
will get the best this is
where what i do and then a week later
after they had researched my blood
in the laboratory on 307
blood values by which they are able to
make an interpretation of
how the vagus nerve is uh influenced
because that was unknown the
their thesis or their uh uh
yeah what they wanted to see is that
if a human is able to influence into the
vagus nerve
then it means he is able to suppress
inflammation that is the cause and
effect
of disease so if this
guy maybe this guy the iceman or wim hof
who just did a world record the day
before now in the feinstein
institute of manhattan doing this
uh doing this experiment maybe he
can do something and let us see and a
week later i got a telephone call
with the results and that came from uh
dr um kevin carmer
dr kevin carmen is an authority in the
field of the extremes extreme athletes
like the climbing mount everest and
things like that
he is always the physician and he wrote
a book
going into the extreme he's the
authority that
he he called me he said if you
are able to reproduce what you have been
doing a week ago there in the feinstein
institute then that is going to
uh mean a huge car
that will be of huge consequences for
human
mankind then he named so many diseases
related to a possible control and
influence on the vagus nerve which i had
shown
for the first time
and i did that and you know what
later i found out that they were uh
sponsored by the farmer these guys so
this the real studies never continued
thursday you were like wow yeah it's
amazing it's a
and then i heard suddenly nothing
anymore then three years later
i got a contact with a university
here in the netherlands and i told a
a a person who was
creating or organizing an event where
people with different
ways of thinking uh something
extraordinary
would uh show what they were capable of
and he asked me do would you be
willing to participate in this event and
i said yes
and then he said he heard my story and
also the feinstein institute in new york
on the vagus nerve and all and i said
hey man
my mission is to show that we all are
able to tap into our system
to learn to control that what causes
disease that is the control of the vagus
nerve
among others and to beat inflammation
willfully and and he said that
are you willing to because i'm a doctor
my other profession is being a a
physician
i got relationships with the professors
in rugbach
university uh physiology would you be
before we go into this event shown in an
experiment
called a called physiological experiment
what you are capable of and what you
state about the vagus nerve
and i said yes and two weeks later we
were in the university
i was 80 minutes immersed in ice
direct contact they took the blood 36 of
these
tubes they took me out and
they had me fully controlled with 20
monitors
this was the strangest experiment they
ever had done
in the university so many professors
came the whole year
it was like a circus and i was there
80 minutes just talking to the people
completely in control while being
exposed
to eyes for 80 minutes my core body
temperature
did not go down my skin temperature
almost
zero degrees like in zero celsius it's
like 30 degrees
uh what is it uh you know freezing
almost yeah 32 almost 32 and then
and my heart rate or fluctuated
it didn't go way up or something no
quite controlled
they took the blood now listen they took
the blood
out of my body 36 of these tubes
and they exposed bacteria which normally
creates a violent reaction on the immune
cells in the
in the blood serum in my case there was
zero reaction zero
you know what happened what happened was
that
that blood because i was in the extreme
i was into the depth of my physiology i
was doing it all consciously
like i'm here in control so the
connection was
completely there and then that blood
is enriched is it has different
properties and that one of the
properties is
that virus and bacteria have no
chance that is who we are in the depth
but nobody wants to know of course and
then they asked me from there
sorry but danica i just continue
then they asked me uh would you be
willing to now vividly so in the life
take a bacteria ejected in your blood
uh while lying on a bed in this hospital
this is an endotoxemia model a e coli
bacteria with the same fla inflammation
markers as covert 19 will be injected
and you will become like normally you
become uh
very sick fever addicts all over agony
muscle aches backaches vomiting things
like that for three to six hours
would you be willing to do this for
science i said
yes of course of course i
did that i did that and then they saw
for the first time a person not becoming
sick and that after the injection i
oh is this where it should work now i
should be very sick
i don't feel it i'm i'm in control
and that is through these breathing
techniques
and through my mind the mindset
we think might ah where is it wim
hof this is according to the psychiatric
uh professors
wim hof has found the secret of placebo
placebo is a psychic medicinal
healing power within us we don't know
how it works
i know how it works i know how to
activate it
and to intensify it more than normally
then it
works normally no so it will
work better than medicine because
placebo
and medicine that people are able to
sell medicine
if it only works one percent more than
the placebo
so now at twenty
or thirty percent more on the placebo
effect of work dollars
and no medicine will be able to beat
this so that that is huge consequences
of course yeah huge consequences and no
side effects and
you're doing it yourself so it's all
amazing
and i i'm with you i 100 believe in it
i'm like you from a young age i thought
different
i felt different something else is out
there i've always been fascinated by how
the universe works how we work
how consciousness works like it's all
really
religions i'm interested in all of them
like
you know i i i'm with you on all that so
you are a great example
as i told you in the beginning and you
see
that our content is real it is built up
it is when we started to think different
we became something out there which
cannot be controlled
which is awesome which is amazing it is
the control of your own
mind i teach people learn to
own your own mind and then
you will uh partake in the unlimited
power of it
you can do whatever you are here for
and the answers and the questions they
are all in
it's called feeling and your feelings
should not be
jeopardized or molested in
any way by stress in any way
go your way so how do you prepare
how do you prepare the space to then go
into
the practice does that make sense like
um
yes no it makes absolutely sense
from now if people listen to this i tell
you
we we as a living in this
western lifestyle we alienated from
our deeper physiology and soon or later
we will uh stress will derive
there from uh for example
cardiovascular related diseases
it doesn't happen if you take cold
showers or
on a regular basis and that is killer
number one it kills millions of people
every year in all the western world
cardiovascular related diseases also
meat eating too much
is also no no good we are not meat
eaters man we are
we are on divorce and we should take
care of this world and
uh don't go into cruelty so much
care more love more be more and be
really in the flesh do yourself go into
the culture however the cold shower is
great
it trains the vascular system to the
best
with our biggest organ of our flesh
literally is our skin so
millions of uh electro receptors and
uh thermal receptors go to the skin with
that the capillaries
capillaries are little blood vessels
and they contain uh uh little muscles
through cold showers you train these
millions of little muscles
you train them and with that the blood
flow goes
a lot better through the system through
your body
it reaches much better these cells
thus it gives much better oxygen
nutrients via vitamins
and the life force itself in the blood
it will reach
the cells a lot better and that last
but not least it is the heart rate that
goes down with 20 to
30 heartbeats a minute 24 hours a day
that means stress is gone you get a lot
more energy
and a lot less stress just by taking
a cold shower and know that this is good
for you
that that this every person in the
in the western world in the hemisphere
where uh cold is
they should swim outside in the winter
and have a dip man
have a dip and go with your dog outside
and have a moment
with a deep moment with yourself it's so
good for us
and this is the way we tackle this
serial killer
called cardiovascular related diseases
and depression and all kinds of things
oh yeah depression too yeah
so cold shower um
being conscious about taking care of the
world through
eating more fruit vegetables and fruit
and and just being more conscious
um getting out into nature right
yes on the ground playing getting
outside being with
animals right so you kind of prepare
your space
you shift your mindset to a more
conscious mindset
so then like enter
in the science what's happening what are
you
actually doing how can we what is the
next step that we can do
once we've really prepared our space yes
gifted what can we actually do what's
the technique
and can you demo it yes
of course anytime the breathing the
breathing we can demo any time
and uh it's amazing
let's just do it but before we do this i
i say
we have created our space and we do all
this
what we you just mentioned then uh
know that nothing escapes your
power of your attention your
consciousness we are built to be
in uh in command over our
uh hormonal system immune system and
metabolic processes
in the cell it sounds all alike but in
the end it is
being happy strong and healthy is who we
are
so when people ask me what is the way to
er to be i what is enlightenment
i say just be happy strong and healthy
the rest is [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
should be blocked out of our lives
so create your own space and with that
space you've got enough
to be once again in full command
create that mindset that belief hey i am
here in command
over my happiness strength and health
because that's the most
logical thing in nature nature didn't
make
and made us to be not in in command
over our well-being of course what are
we going to
teach our children that we are not well
that we have actually no control
that we can control all the world we can
kill it and with atom bombs and we can
go to mars
and we cannot and we cannot be happy
strong and healthy right
we missed out and so know
that we are built to be happy strong and
healthy and pass it on to our children
and
be in harmony with nature it's a sounds
logic
it is logical this is pure science
showing that it is there the created
advertising
and and imagery through uh hollywood
and next year i'm gonna make a hollywood
film next year
anyway so that's the best marketing i
think
for this method with genuine good actors
hey that's amazing but hey
superman batman is the iceman
and he is you man and the human
it is time that the human is going to
stand up
and bring happiness strength and health
in his family and it is
surroundings and how the science is
showing
all this already now let's demo
let's feel because feeling is
understanding
so feeling
uh feeling is
the ability to go into the deeper space
of your own
brain more than the thinking brain which
is the human brain the
evolutionary new part of our brain
is the is the thinking brain the
neocortex
now with this exercise we will tap into
the limbic brain into the deeper part of
the brain
and then it showed that these breathing
techniques within 10 minutes
are able to go deeper than a person
is able to go after uh training
mindfulness exercising mindfulness
for four hours four years this is in
brain scans
demonstrated so let's go and
i always say feeling is at the real
understanding
so i asked also the the viewer
who is looking at this listening to this
to relax now moment we go for five
minutes
maybe we go for two rounds
into the deeper parts of our brain and
brain controls
the blood flow in the in actually the
deepest part of
our brain and with that
activation of neural activity
you never felt before that's amazing
i'm excited i love going into new parts
of my brain and possibility and new
modalities that are natural so this is
so right up my alley
great there we go so everybody relax
a relaxed body is able to store up
oxygen because the tissue relaxes and
it's able to enter
there we are relaxed now we have a belly
and we have a chest and we take a full
breath in
can thread be through the nose and
through the mouth we exhale
so fully in through the nose
and exhale through the mouth
fully in through the nose
go with your mind to the breath for an
exhale
fully
exhale
pull here
let it go
be with your mind with the breath and
the breath is able to grow
with the mind pull in
letting go
and fooling it again yes
fully in again 15 more
boolean anything that you feel different
it's okay lightness in the head
loominess in the body tingling it's all
all right
boolean letting go we take on that
rhythm
and we are going to change the
biochemistry it's all happening
boolean and letting go
boolean letting go
oh yeah let the mind go
there is no time there is only feeling
because your breath goes in deeply
past your conditions amount you go
deeper and deeper this is no hypnosis or
anything
just a breath is simply able to go
deeper
into our biochemistry and make it the
way nature meant to be
bring blood flow and activity of the
nervous system
suddenly alive we first
charge up the body fully in
letting go five more
full in letting go
for more anything that feels different
breathe into it boolean
letting go
pull in letting go
two more pull in
letting go
here comes the last one fully in
oh let it go
and stop after the exhalation
just let it go and stop
and the witness
it's all all right we have blowing off
the carbon dioxide we are very alkaline
right now
we ox energized our bodies
more than in science was thought
possible
and thus we are able to stay
with empty lungs and there is no need
for breathing
here we change the biochemistry and the
depth
giving signals to the survival part
of our brain the brainstem
whenever you feel don't yes don't
succumb to the reflexes there's no need
still when you feel the need to breathe
in breathe in
breathe in and hold
squeeze to your head toward the right
five four three
two one and you let it go
okay let it go now we do another round
now we will go all hundred seconds
without air in the lungs and feel
comfortable
and then at that moment so many things
happen within the body all thought of in
science impossible
but anybody can do it okay let's go
mind your breath fully
let it go
fully let it go
27 more boolean
let it go
mind your breathing that's all
follow your breath
23 to go truly
let it go
boolean let it go
21 more boolean take a bullion
let it go
19 more just give yourself
this moment to make the change in the
depth
to regain a neurological connection
18 mo
okay boolean
letting go
boolean letting go
16 more boolean
letting go
boolean letting go
11 more boolean if you feel light headed
loominess all all right
ten more last ten boolean
let it go
let it go
pull in
let it go
[Music]
boolean
there we go
last five oh what feels different
all all right
letting go
four boolean
letting go
three boolean
letting go
boolean
yeah let me go
one more pull in
letting go here comes the last one
boolean
let it go and stop after the exhalation
it's our witness
just be
all all right
all physiological in the depth
amazing what is happening
what we can do in an instant
in 10 minutes we can go deeper
than people doing mindfulness four hours
a day
for years that's what you experience
right now deep
blood flow neural activity
inside the mid brain and the deepest
part can explain all
it is at you to experience
with that you learn to control
the stress
you do this and you are stressed stress
will go away anyone
whenever you feel the urge to breathe
you breathe in you hold you squeeze to
your head
yes hold and then squeeze to your head
five four squeeze more
three two
one and let it go
you know what danica you get you don't
need to yeah
you don't need to do uh be mystical
about it
it is mystical you are in the midst
of unknown territory of the depth of
your own brain
what's happening then what's happening i
mean first off i think it's important to
explain what i feel which i didn't tell
you the other thing that i'm
really not very good at yet is holding
my breath
i i think i i remember seeing a picture
of you at
um laird hamilton and gabby reese's
house in their ice bucket
i i just recognized it because i've been
there and i've done it
and um you know she tries to she's
led me through some breathing exercises
and of course being underwater and
holding your breath is something that
they do a lot of
and um i found that i'm not very good at
it so
uh i i don't even know if i've ever held
my breath for a minute to be honest
um but you know you really
feel um a peacefulness
and a little bit of tingling
through your arms especially like just
kind of
as you drop into it and
you know i could feel myself the second
time the second round to try and
literally
try and be of the observer for myself to
see myself holding my breath longer
to see myself as not time and space
dependent
but just being dependent and that if we
just didn't have
time as this barometer i wouldn't be
scared of a hundred seconds i would just
be
and um it's but it's very hard it's
it is very hard but uh but that's
because i don't practice it
right if i practiced it then you get
good at anything so
i mean repetition is always a really
good teacher so i'm sure that
you know a big part of this has to be
repetition is that right
yes and uh you know i have people
who are 80 years 90 years
and the oldest participant is 98 years
they can hold their breath as well and
you know
for minutes for minutes
you know what they say well i don't know
what happened but i
i never even when i was a young kid i
could not hold my breath so long
thank you thank just a joy
to be able to say to
hold the breath for two minutes and when
you are 90
and older it it's just bloody amazing
it's good so what's happening tell me go
science on me i want to hear
i want to understand good so
what happens is we first oxygenate
we blow off the carbon dioxide
carbon dioxide actually builds up in the
body
and that's why we breathe we breathe
because we have too much carbon dioxide
in the body
and then you have to breathe and then
oxygen gets in
and you become more alkaline and we have
the right
ph level that's why we breathe
to maintain in the equilibrium of the ph
level okay so what we do now
is bring down the carbon dioxide
we bring down the carbon dioxide thus
the alkalinity in the body
is suddenly way up
and that means it takes a lot of time
to get back to the carbon dioxide
trigger
to to the carbon dioxide to be
signaling i need to breathe again it's
not needed because the alkalinity is so
high
and the carbon dioxide is so low
so in that time you don't need to
breathe
you don't feel it and when you don't
feel it
in the brain now the primitive brain
you have parameters for oxygen
and the oxygen parameter is stellar
that's the survival parameter
which is directly connected to the
adrenal axis
the adrenaline the adrenal is to when
there is danger there is
adrenaline and there is no oxygen that
is
danger and when the danger comes in
then when there is no danger because we
manipulate it
it's all within our own brain through
doing this breathing technique we
manipulate these parts in the brain
and suddenly we become the master over
the hormonal secretion
of the uh adrenal axis
and what happens when the adrenal axis
is
being triggered and activated through
the lack of oxygen built up
in the body yet the body is still
alkaline
so uh but that the primitive part of our
brain
doesn't understand it it's reactionary
then it shoots out the adrenaline
through the body
what happens then it kills cancer cells
it activates stem cells
it uh recycles damaged cells
it does all the good to our body and it
brings down
instantly the inflammation the
inflammatory markers in the blood
and that it's magical it's magical
what it does on a conscious level
with our bodies it has been in 2014
we were the first one in medical history
to show that we were able to tap into
the uh hormonal system the endocrine
system
the adrenal adrenaline dopamine
serotonin
all those uh this was unheard of
in science and uh into the immune system
which was unheard
and into the autonomic nervous system
was
all unhurt these are powers
which were always outside of our willful
control
considered in science and now suddenly
12
people after 16 thousand
hundred and thirty four people doing the
same endotoxemia model
injection of a part of a bacteria making
people
very sick for three to six hours sixteen
thousand hundred
thirty-four became all sick and then
suddenly 12 people
did not became sick there we
fundamentally
changed the perspectives of what people
are able to do
with bacteria baxa and virus and that
should
have been taken up by it it has changed
the
university books but something that
doesn't make money
doesn't get out in the open too much so
that
there we come in and we show that
through these breathing techniques
you can tap into the deepest part of
your brain you can tap into the dna
i'm doing the studies right now with the
top researchers in san francisco
into the dna into the bone marrow the t
cells and the b
cells and all that is happening
and in the psychiatry how to be
depression
we can do all this this
in the end this podcast is good
to make people curious curious
hey guys there is more than meets the
eye
it's all in and it's beautiful and
that's you
you know you're talking about going into
the dna and all of those things and
um one of the things that's always
that's been on my mind is
this idea of um
through my own curiosities and
through my own experiences and
people i've talked to is more of the
ancestral
lineage about the memory of the cells
and you know
how much of this life do we come
into history
of thousands of years ago while we've
got the primitive brain about running
from
lions and tigers and bears oh my um but
also
all of the trauma and drama that
happened in its past
so you know reprogramming that
is this is is critical you know you see
people that have
you know chronic depression or chronic
anxiety
any of these things addictions and you
just wonder
how much comes into this life
through the cells and so
what are you what do you know about that
i'm very curious about that oh the
genetical past
and the genetical heritage and
the enlightenment of being
comes with freeing the spirit the
captivated spirits within our genetical
encrypted codes are we
able to get into the dna this is what
i'm showing
now we are into the studies to go into
the dna
with top researchers because if i talk
about the ancestors
like the natives do i bless your
ancestors
your forefathers and your foremothers
and
beings of before and wants to come
a then [ __ ] you know but if i'm
showing
that all the trauma or why
things happen in your life actually are
very much
related with what happens uh within your
genetical
encrypted codes laid in there through
the lineage
of your ancestors of your forefathers
and foremothers
which is trauma and drama the good and
the bad
and you are here to make a bad good
that's your mission that's your being
there is the
enlightenment but we are schooled not to
go
too deep in ourselves we have school to
serve a system man i want to
serve enlightenment i want to do the
good within myself
and within you and within the next and
within the next
with the healing comes my soul and the
soul
is what i want when i did and when
you did what you did and i did all these
records
then only then i got a hold of my own
mind
and the first thing that came to my mind
is i want to help the world
i want to help humanity i want to help
all living beings
i want harmony and love for everybody
and everything
and now i am so far as a drop out from
school
to teach the professors how to go and to
tap
into the dna into the encrypted lineage
of a genetical cult of the past of our
ancestors
because there is the love there is the
care whatever happened in the past
we are able to heal we are not
born half we are born holy
let's be holy and make it together
happen
and the rest should not be there we are
here
the guide is happy strong and healthy
and the [ __ ] has come through many
ways
just get it out with the power of your
concentrated minds because you got
all the tools to get rid of what should
not be there
to be able to do your beautiful work um
i love that you say that we are the new
gladiators
yes so cool that and that's
that's what it is all the past has been
accumulated
to the now to the here and now
50 years ago the
the apollo the the apollo project
which went to the moon had
so many bites the whole thing the
commander
center in houston and and the rocket and
all these people that goes now
less in the iphone right now there are
more bites more control
more uh possibilities and that is the
fruit of our mind
it is time that the neurology of our
mind
gets within our control within
our command and with that command we
finally are able to
solve the riddle of our existence which
is love
which is enlightenment which is bringing
light
to the ear and not not to be happy not
to be dark
to be light to be loving for each other
we don't i don't need to go to the moon
nor to mars
not to get nuts or on the milky way
and i don't need chocolate i want to be
here unconditionally
in love every moment and pass it on to
my children
and all the living beings around me
that's it wim i would love to do your
what is it three or four days that you
do
yeah yeah that's in their opponent yeah
actually is amazing
there people find their simple
uh purpose in in being in one and a half
day i see
people coming together in a way they
could not understand
before and and it's always the same
thing
it happens and when it happens it's when
the shields go away the attitude goes
away
the paradigm goes away and we are
stripped to who we are and what we are
the powerful souls
all coming together in love and very
strong
by the way because on day four we all go
in freezing temperatures and everybody
is able to do it
yeah my biggest fears are i
i the cold holding my breath all of that
stuff and so
what i also know about all of that is
that if that is
those are my my fears that's exactly
where i need to go
yes yes you will see it's it's
it's amazing how simple and effective
all this is and you did you
share your part of your work and journey
and it's
amazing my wife said uh
danica yeah she has a one indie cars or
something
you know these these guys man
i would be scared shitless if i would do
what you have done you know to sit
behind the cover
yeah so we're here to share our gift
that is
natural to us but unbelievable to others
they can't imagine going 230 or 40 miles
an hour they can't imagine going under a
sheet of ice and holding your breath for
so long
they can't imagine but for us it's
natural and it's so important to be able
to
and that natural being we want to give
to
everybody yeah yeah find yourself
yeah there it is start aiming
yeah good well thank you so much
amazing yeah that was that's really fun
i thank you for leading us in that
that demo so is that what you would do
you would do that two to three rounds
right
yes you know
thank you for your commitment to
humanity and you know as your mother
said
when you were born i will make him a
missionary
and you found your purpose and yeah
i resonate deeply with a quote that's in
your book that is
my favorite quote by henry ford and
that's
whether you think you can or you think
you can't
you're right yes the power of the mind
is incredible
so thank you for thank you for inspiring
us all to
uh deepen that belief and that feeling
and that
um knowledge of the
metaphysical and of the things that
cannot be seen
and then to go even deeper into the
science to help us truly understand
because sometimes words aren't enough
for some people they need to see the
science and
you have subjected yourself to um
to doing that for us so
many thanks thank you so much and thank
you
very much too we are both working on the
same path
and let's keep on this beautiful journey
and discover
so much more yeah thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button